oh and thank you to everybody and all
the the gentlemen that have been in my
dms i love reading the messages um
they are um
inspiring to say the least
nene leakes shares her thoughts on
dating following the death of her
husband greg
hey guys
it's your favorite girly girl
miss nene leakes how y'all doing
on her instagram story nene shouts out
all the people making her feel loved
after greg's death last month thank you
again to everybody that's been stopping
by the lounge showing me a lot of love
uh jesus christ thank you to ceelo green
who just stopped in and had his son's
birthday party there thank all of you
guys i love you guys thank you so much
for loving me nene also touches on
everyone who's apparently been sliding
into her dms oh and thank you to
everybody and all the the gentlemen that
have been in my dms
thank y'all too
hey
the reality star does go on to clarify
her priorities at the present moment
i'm just over here just doing me right
now you know but uh anyway hey i love
reading the messages um
they are
inspiring to say the least
thank you
nene's message follows a recent night
out at her lenethia lounge in atlanta
she shared these photos to instagram
hanging out with marlo hampton lamar
odom and cynthia bailey have you had a
chance to talk to nene and how she doing
since greg passed away i have i have on
monday cynthia shared with e.t what that
night meant to everyone who came out to
support their friend
actually
was lucky enough to get a private moment
with her my husband and i were not able
to make it to
greg's celebration so i took a little
trip with my girl marlo over to the la
nithia lounge
and uh we hung out
so we got a chance to catch up and i got
a chance to give her you know my
condolences in person and just give her
a hug following greg's death nene held a
celebration of life at the lounge
honestly he is one of the nicest men
i've ever met in my life
to be there was a no-brainer her
housewives co-star kenya moore opened up
to e.t about attending the touching
service i was there to support you know
greg
never ever treated me any differently
whether i was feuding with nene or not
and for that i respected him so much and
he was just a kind gentle
caring supportive man and she was really
lucky to have him i have good days and
bad days but um
[Music]
yeah they say it's normal so
some phase them up it's amazing down
nene's been sharing small life updates
on instagram ever since greg's death
including how she's coping with grief
you know i have a whole group of people
that's coming to my house every day
doing different stuff with me so trying
to keep my mind off of
you know
the events that recently happened love
you guys pushing through
pushing
you